Traductor: Paula Motter
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Los europeos del siglo XV creyeron
haber encontrado una cura milagrosa:
un remedio para la epilepsia,
la hemorragia, los hematomas, las náuseas
y prácticamente cualquier
otro tipo de problema de salud.
Este polvo marrón
podía incorporarse en bebidas,
usarse como ungüento
o ingerirse directamente por boca.
Se lo conocía como "mumia"
y se obtenía triturando
carne humana momificada.
La palabra "caníbal" data
de la época de Cristóbal Colón.
Incluso se especula
con que él mismo inventó el término.
Tras desembarcar en la isla de Guadalupe,
Colón escribió en sus primeras
crónicas a la reina de España
que los pueblos indígenas
eran amables y pacíficos,
aunque mencionó rumores
sobre la existencia de los "caribes",
una tribu que, tras violentos ataques,
cocinaban y comían a sus prisioneros.
Como resultado, la reina Isabel concedió
el permiso de capturar y esclavizar
a toda persona que comiera carne humana.
Al ver que la isla no contenía
el oro que buscaba,
Colón empezó a llamar a quien
se resistía a sus saqueos y secuestros
con el nombre de "caribe".
Con el tiempo, la palabra "caribe"
derivó en "canibe" y de allí en "caníbal".
El término, inicialmente usado
por los colonizadores
para deshumanizar a los indígenas,
se aplicó desde entonces para designar
a todo aquel que comiera carne humana.
Así pues, los antecedentes de este vocablo
carecen de fundamentos concluyentes,
pero lo cierto es que el canibalismo
tiene una historia real y más compleja.
Ha adoptado diversas formas
que, a veces, como la mumia,
no incluye partes reconocibles
del cuerpo humano.
Las razones que llevaron
a la práctica del canibalismo
también fueron variando.
En distintas culturas y épocas,
ha habido evidencia de canibalismo
con fines de supervivencia.
Por ejemplo, en casos de hambruna,
asedio o expediciones malogradas,
las personas involucradas
debían comer cadáveres humanos
o bien morir de inanición.
Sin embargo, algunas culturas
llegaron a normalizar
la práctica de comer carne humana
en ciertas situaciones de la vida.
A raíz de relatos falsos
como los de Colón,
se desconoce a ciencia cierta
si el canibalismo era tan común.
Pero aún existen algunos ejemplos
de prácticas caníbales
aceptadas en la cultura que las adoptan.
Tal es el caso del canibalismo medicinal
practicado en Europa en la época de Colón.
A partir del siglo XV,
la demanda de mumia aumentó.
En un principio, esta demanda fue suplida
con momias robadas en Egipto,
pero, al poco tiempo, ya no alcanzó para
sostenerla exclusivamente por este medio,
y surgieron oportunistas que robaban
cadáveres de los cementerios en Europa
para suplir la demanda de mumia.
El consumo de este remedio
se extendió cientos de años.
Llegó a integrar el índice de Merck,
una conocida enciclopedia de medicina,
hasta el siglo XX.
Y el polvo de momias no fue el único
remedio hecho a base de carne humana
que circulaba en Europa.
La sangre, líquida o en polvo,
se usaba para tratar la epilepsia,
en tanto que con el hígado,
los cálculos biliares,
aceite extraído del cerebro humano
y corazones reducidos a polvo
se hacían mezclas medicinales
de uso popular.
En China, los registros escritos
de prácticas caníbales socialmente
aceptadas datan de casi 2000 años.
Una forma muy particular de canibalismo
parece haber sido el canibalismo filial:
las hijas y los hijos adultos
ofrecían una porción de su propia carne
a sus padres.
Se recurría a esta práctica como
último intento por curar la enfermedad
de uno de los progenitores
sin poner en riesgo a los hijos,
pues solían ofrecer parte de la pierna
o, con menos frecuencia, un dedo.
Otra forma de canibalismo culturalmente
censurado se ve en los ritos funerarios.
Quizá la práctica más conocida
fue la adoptada por la tribu fore
de Nueva Guinea.
A mediados del siglo XX, los miembros
de esta comunidad anunciaban,
en lo posible por adelantado,
sus preferencias funerarias.
A veces, pedían a los familiares
que se reunieran a consumir
el cuerpo del occiso.
Lo trágico es que estos rituales
destinados a honrar a los muertos
propagaban una mortal enfermedad
entre los miembros de la tribu: el "kuru".
En medio de las novelas de ficción,
las prácticas comprobables
y los grandes interrogantes que aún
existen en nuestro conocimiento del tema,
no hay una única historia
sobre el canibalismo.
Lo que sabemos a ciencia cierta
es que hay gente que ha comido a otra,
gente que se ha ofrecido a ser comida
y gente que ha acusado a otros
de comer carne humana
durante milenios.